- And most of all while
I've got your attention,
I love you guys.
Thanks for all the love.
This Instagram
storm over the last
10, 14 days has
been a whole lot of fun.
It's brought a lot to me.
As much to me as it has for you.
Oh and look, I signed
a shit load of books.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Sideways" by Mad Real)
- [Gary] Shit.
This is the 60 Second Club box?
Fuck.
- [DRock] Careful
what you ask for.
- [Gary] Yep.
Alright, Claire.
It's coming, Claire.
One.
Alright, Kyle.
Alex. Peter.
This is fun.
One of the biggest reasons a lot
of people don't do things for
their community, like engage,
or reply or make
videos in reply or
do giveaways where
you have to sign stuff or
two and three minute meeting,
15 minute meetings via FaceTime
or shadow for the day.
The reason people don't do
that is 'cause it takes up time.
I just landed from L.A.
Got a lot of work done which set
up another five to six things
that I have to take care of
right now and this is gonna
eat into those 10 minutes that
I just don't have and I need
and I'm okay with that because
I believe in it and it's
what I want to do.
And it's how I give back to
you guys for your attention and
that's the value exchange
and I'm cool with it.
But boy, do most people
not want to go there.
Most people don't
like the process.
They just want what's
on the other side of it.
And especially
when they make it,
they kind of want to
reap the benefits.
The thing for me is
I'll never make it.
It's always going
to be a journey, right?
I mean, first and foremost,
I created a ridiculous journey.
I love how people don't really
understand how all-time wealthy
you have to be just
to buy a football team.
So I put myself in a corner of
trying to create one of those
situations and then
I went about it in
a very tried-and-true way.
Which means, for me
by my definition,
that I,
I'm trying to not only
buy the New York Jets,
which would mean I would have
to become a billionaire which is
very difficult, I'm doing it
while I in parallel give back.
Unlike a lot of executives
and CEOs and entrepreneurs
they put 100% of their
efforts towards their goal.
They punt everything else.
They do not give back to the
entrepreneurial community.
individuals in the world and the
truth is new technology
has happened so the titans,
the mavericks, she didn't have
time and more importantly she
didn't have technology in
1950 to document like this.
1960 document like this.
1970 to document like this.
1980 document like this.
1990 to document like this.
Lloyd, you got your book.
And so, that's
what happened, right?
So, what I'm trying to do is
really difficult in my mind
and I enjoy it for that which is
giving back along the way while
trying to achieve
something ridiculous.
Which is battling on two fronts
which is very difficult
and that's fine by
me because truth is
I wouldn't have
it any other way.
I don't want the New York Jets
if I don't also show the
blueprint for the
next guy and girl
who want their New York Jets.
I don't want it if I don't give
back to the game that's given me
so much opportunity and so
I'm documenting this journey.
Building a Honey Empire,
of building the
cleanest and best
and not most passionate
but truest community
of anybody online right now.
That's a big ambition of
mine because I know
I have an advantage.
For me, that's a foregone
conclusion because
I want so little in return.
I know that I'm giving away a
lot more than I'm asking for in
return 'cause when you're not
asking for anything you're in a
very, very, very good spot.
To me, your attention and you
picking me is more than enough.
I do not need to make
$86 a piece off
of you in a e-book.
I don't need to sign you up for
a $20,000 a month mastermind.
I do not need those things so
that is how I am
going through it,
DRock and Vayner Nation.
And Gordon, you
get the last one.
That's not true, perfect,
Thank You Econ,
you know what?
So symbolic that
this was at the bottom.
I love it.
This makes me so happy.
Most underrated book
that I've written.
Least selling book of the four
business books and the one that
is so, so tried-and-true to
what I'm actually doing here
and so thank you.
And thank you, Jean.
And back to the grind.
- [Tyler] G, can I see your
license when you get a second?
- [Gary] Yep.
What are you guys doing?
Like registration or something?
- [Tyler] Yep.
- I can't believe I was able to
figure that out just from the
little pump that you give Avi.
(group laughter)
I'm literally one of the
smartest people on Earth.
(group laughter)
Where's my phone?
There it is.
I'm one of the
smartest people on Earth.
Where's my phone?
("Sideways" by Mad Real)
India's live, let's see.
Shoulda said,
"GaryVee here. Influencer."
(DRock laughs)
It's me.
No, it's me.
- [DRock] (laughs)
She can't hear you.
- India, it's always me.
She's like I don't
think it's Gary.
Meanwhile she's literally one
of the few people on Earth
that knows it is me.
Gotta call her.
(phone ringing)
- [India] Hello?
- Of course, it's me.
You're one of the few people
on Earth that knows it's me.
(India laughs)
- [India] This is the greatest
phone call I've ever received.
AJ just walked by in a suit.
He looked great.
- Well, I'm gonna
have a suit, too.
- [India] Okay, cool.
- Alright, see ya.
- [Tyler] Hi, India.
- [India] You stopped
my livestream.
- Alright, bye.
- [Tyler] Paul Pierce,
signed jersey.
- [Gary] That's what he wants?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Gary] No, you know
that I hate Paul Pierce.
You can tell him,
right now literally,
That's insane that he said that.
- [Tyler] I know.
- He literally, literally
could have said anybody,
anybody. Larry Bird.
He could of said,
I don't know, Sherman Douglas.
He coulda said anybody.
Chauncey Billups who played
for them for four minutes.
Antoine Walker,
he could have said anybody.
But Paul Pierce,
I hate Paul Pierce.
Tell him, tell him, tell him.
Actually, DRock will
give you this clip.
Just tell him, he blew it. Wow.
- [Tyler] My favorite selfie
of all time is Paul Pierce.
And my favorite on their
current roster is (inaudible).
- [Gary] Great to be
back in New York.
I can feel it right away.
It's in my blood, I love it.
It's a totally different vibe.
I'm also really getting
back into the mindset of
not filming which is good.
Really enjoyed the
last week and a half.
An enormous time
to engage with fans.
Especially through
Instagram with all their
new features so that was fun.
Football season's over.
Going to honor AJ tonight
at a foundation which
I'm excited about.
And moving forward.
Moving forward.
And getting ready to go away
for this weekend for two weeks.
That's that time of year.
We're debating a lot here about
what we're gonna do because
it's really, it's truly the time
where I want to be checked out
and we made this
commitment to DailyVee,
so, I don't know.
We'll see. Debating.
(camera focusing sounds)
Off to AJ's event.
Just had a nice meeting.
VaynerSports, full effect.
Some good VaynerMedia calls.
Livin'.
("Sideways" by Mad Real)